the Joe Rogan experience I'm gonna send
I'll send it to you right now but is
this I sent it to I know I sent it to
Callen because he's in Shaba both dog
freaks but it doesn't even make any
sense like you look at the video and you
go like what the [ __ ] this one nope
that's not it but let me see this dog
you see that one
look at the body on that thing little
stud jacked here he goes
boy oh he's running up the wall I've
seen this it's crazy this stuff is
insane it's crazy that dog just jumped
it looks like he jumped 18 feet in the
air he did at least right yeah that
looks like 18 feet and he bites the rope
and so that it pulls him down slowly so
he doesn't get hurt that's amazing and
the guy helps the guy catches him too
dude that's a [ __ ] crazy dog pitbull
can leap 4 meter walls what four meters
there's out regular dogs man look at
this see that you fetch it holy [ __ ]
that is incredible find this [ __ ] dog
oh also I wanted to ask you about this
have you seen mass wrestling do you know
what that is its mass wrestling do you
know this type that in this is nuts
mass wrestling before I forget it I
wanted to tell you about it people like
there's like a there's like a bar look
at this what are they doing there's like
a bar do they both have to grip onto and
they're pulling it are they gonna get
legs how many people died doing this
isn't this [ __ ] insane it's a lot of
weight
ton I mean dude look at these two dudes
it's all that's all grip and leg
strength and [ __ ] it's wild [ __ ] I got I
was I watched like 50 videos of it I got
so soaked into it I was like why why are
people doing this
it's like tug of war with like a staple
with or something stable you know I'm
sending it to you right now Jamie you
gotta see this it looks like these guys
they blurring out that guy's hog I was
like that was a hog it was butt ass
naked I mean originally guy on the right
like this little pixelation I originally
got into this because I was jerking off
to it that's why I wanted to see that
hold on stop wholly honest like this
this yeah like up the guy on the left is
winning but he's all arms look at his
little bitch-ass legs I got
money on the guy on the right I don't
like the way the guy on the right or the
left rather has over developed his arms
and underdeveloped his legs that guy is
gonna quit the guy on the left mm-hmm
yeah he's got no legs down he's gonna
give out the guy on the right is Russian
it looks like he's from a high in the
middle of Siberia
his whole family lives in a yurt he left
he did not run look at his legs look at
his calves that guy's not he's not fit
see told you that's why I'm a good MMA
commentator called it I know when I see
it dude that's just like he's jacked you
look at his upper body and his forearms
and [ __ ] and his biceps and his
shoulders I'm like the guy's jacked
there's no leg strength there but he's
got zero in his legs which means his
mind is weak that's what it means his
mind is weak he wants everybody to think
he's strong but he's not doing the real
hard work nobody gives a [ __ ] if you're
doing squats you don't nobody notices
okay you do push-ups and you do bench
press and your [ __ ] tits pop out
everybody sees it
watch this dog [ __ ] you ain't even gonna
believe this
this doesn't even seem real look at this
this dog flies I think that's a Belgian
Malinois flies whole just lies and then
they have them land on a cushion which
is pretty sweet look he jumps off that
guy's shoulders I'm saying guys
shoulders but that's got to be 20 really
jumps I mean it's at least 15 he's at
least 15 feet in the air what's even
cooler is that he's flying the it send
it official on Instagram want all one
word send it official that's one of them
Instagram page that has a bunch of crazy
[ __ ] on it it's always there's a lot of
those that are pretty good I follow a
lot of them well the original like to
send it quote you know that's from
you've seen those guys that have you
seen those guys he's like come on Marty
stand that knee just like jump yes do
that makes me laugh so hard
every time he's like I'm a [ __ ] sand
it truck it just shoots it off a shitty
[ __ ] ramp hold my beer wasa a [ __ ]
sand it have you seen hold this beer on
Twitter you're seeing that called my
beer yeah yes I think it's hold this be
able to hold this is the actual Twitter
account but it says hold my beers the
name of it
that one is that's a hope my baby can't
go wrong with that one no that stuff's
hilarious if you can deal with it if you
can deal with it because sometimes
you're gonna watch people that are gonna
get absolute brain dam yeah but I love
it whatever it's not me there's one
where a dude is standing on a hill and a
bale of hay it's coming towards him and
this bale hay looks like in my way six
seven hundred pounds right and it's huge
he's taking he jumps up into the air
like he's trying to get over it and he
doesn't make it
and he goes [ __ ] flying he got hit by
a bus I love that [ __ ] I mean the dude
goes if you ever seen a bait one of
those big-ass yes circle bigger than
this table huge those are so [ __ ]
heavier than a truck tire yes they're so
heavy and this [ __ ] thought he was
gonna jump over it my favorite is uh
mostly overestimating how well they're I
mean the fact he's alive boom I mean he
did a full flip through the air that
[ __ ] thing is so heavy you there's no
way you would pick that up you know my
favorite is the medicine balls when
people bump them you know and they would
be able do medicine ball challenge where
they run at each other
no well you've never seen that they'll
both grab a medicine ball run each other
full speed and jump and whoever gets hit
the furthest but sometimes people do
with their kids and like a dad he's just
[ __ ] her you see a kid go flying
thirty feet in the road Jesus Christ oh
that's my favorite [ __ ] I love there's
one on there that's like failarmy or
FAIL Blog or something and they show the
same kind of [ __ ] stuff or people
just have this crazy idea of what they
would do to get away from things that
other people aren't doing totally
[ __ ] inside step outside stuff that
was it that we jump over it that's
always been an inside joke in MMA forums
about sidestepping that if someone is
coming after me I just [ __ ] side side
up man a sidestep broke most people just
don't know what to do they stand there
freeze I sidestep get out of the way
like I got it planned out people are
gonna swarm you swarm you like a zombie
try to bite your face like we're
sidestepping him dude sidestep sidestep
them all but people think they could do
that if their [ __ ] bull was coming
after me I just step aside
Matadors are [ __ ] with the little
[ __ ] poncho I'll use your
we'll use your fake martial arts videos
those guys those are my [ __ ] - those
are my favorite I resist putting those
videos up cuz there's so many of they
get sent to me they're so funny I can't
keep putting them up the guy there's
like a wind book technique it's like
with his breath is like comes the other
guy great page on Instagram Mick dojo is
it mcdo Joe or mcdo Joe life I forget
which one it is we told you life
wait a Mickey Mick dojo they call me
like a dojo is a martial arts school
nick dojos like a mall martial art
school that's what we would call like
cheesy shitty martial arts schools McDo
Joe watch this guy watch this guy go
fullscreen on this one this one's
[ __ ] preposterous the guy comes down
with a sword and he uses his power and
the guy goes flying I buy this I buy
every second I was old Japanese guy -
goofy white guys who would have been the
guys in Boyle Heights they were saying
we're here for your community we get out
we don't want you it would be the same
guys these old dorky liberal guys who
probably call themselves feminists and
they just fly into the air with our
Aikido suits on dude he is [ __ ] this
guy up he's [ __ ] this dude he leads
him around and then [ __ ] up to the
ground well you know as a feminist I'm
more likely to get tossed around it's
almost like a coordinated dance it's so
silly they're all so silly what is that
one next to it the guy with the karate
outfit what is he gonna do it's not a
girl or a guy oh my god he's doing flips
on his head breaking the boards and then
flipping onto his feet
so he's crushing or the blocks of stone
with his head yep what does it sound
like
[Applause]
oh my god he's doing it like like
flipping one more yeah he did it if that
ever comes up and you need to flip and
land on someone's dick that guy's a
Taekwondo outfit on that doesn't make
any sense to me
that's so weird what could those be made
out of the shittiest rock known to man
like if you pissed on it will probably
break it can't be Rock yeah it's it's
some sort of shitty ass bitch-ass
concrete you got that bag of bitch-ass
concrete we order hey man you got some
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] ass cream we're gonna
[ __ ] people up drinking [ __ ] with my
head this uh but there's a lot of people
out there that buy into that stupid
stuff man
[Applause]